I I told you before we started rolling
that uh the world's a little blurry I
really love that documentary because
it's about the process and I love
anything
that shows both sides of
Fame success in a realistic lens and
what I you know first of all the gap
between
the journey between you two in a bedroom
you put a blanket over your head
sometimes I know uh bickering you
prodding having arguments you know
arguing with your mom in the kitchen
um and man are you intimidating I know
when you're Billy when you're mad I have
you know uh a teenage daughter I get
terrified so when I'm watching the
documentary it's as scary to me as any
horror movie because you'll just shoot
those eyes at someone and you're not
even trying you're just staring at them
and if I were your mom I would jump out
the window I know 16 year old me is a
scary thought it's a it's a scary sight
to see I mean I I think about myself and
think about the people that I used to
have to make them be put through being
around me at that age and I feel very I
can't I can't even it makes me sick to
my stomach thinking about if I had to be
around the younger Billy it really
freaks me out sometimes yeah scary girl
what about you I mean Phineas you seem
and this is again this is just from uh
the documentary and and performances you
seem like someone who doesn't lose his
but do you sometimes
yeah oh yeah Phineas is an incredible
actor
incredible so so I mean genuinely are we
talking about like backstage you're are
you kicking stuff are you smashing
things should we tell stories yeah I
think that's what we're here to do uh I
was as a as a little kid as like a
five-year-old six-year-old I'm told that
I was very explosive and I have a
infinite supply of Rage yeah
what an explanation but hi but I don't
think anyone
um should uh be on the receiving end of
it so I try to just
you know quell it I try to I try to go
empathy first but there's always rage
below it my friend my friend Ricky
always reminds me that at one point he
said he said
do you have a lot of rage
which is a testament to like being
around me too much maybe to see me sort
of at the Guitar Center staring off in
the middle distance and uh and he said
do you have a lot of rage and I said are
you joking that was apparently looking
at us that is all I have but I don't
yeah but I don't I don't scream at
anybody true or false yeah yeah yeah I
would agree no I would agree I would
agree I I uh uh my team will disagree I
have no anger issues
what are you are you an uh I
don't think I'm well you guys can back
me up I am not an I don't
everyone but whose mortgage is paid by
yeah I remember before you answer yeah
your checks don't come out till Monday
it's a full panel of people
um
can we meet you behind the building
later
I think I've worked for him longer than
anybody and I will say he's not an
but he has made an art form of
being passive aggressive because the way
I grew up the way I grew up is I do have
I I relate to Phineas because I have a
lot of
anger I have a temper and what I and I
used to really get angry when I had a
bad temper when I was a kid and what I
did is I learned I grew up in a family
very unlike yours where we weren't
supposed to express negative things
Catholic we're not supposed to express
and no one was around saying well how do
you feel about what just happened
there's none of that yeah so
um there was nobody expressing any of
that so what happened was there's a lot
of pent up anger and what I learned is
you could express anger in this I could
let it out like a teapot there's a
little hole that it's coming out but
it's shooting out at great force and
it's passive aggression it's me saying
oh wow that sounds like a wonderful idea
and people like and I mastered this
thing of being able to talk to somebody
for a bit who I was really mad at and we
had a pleasant conversation and then I'd
leave and they'd think I think we had a
pleasant conversation oh my God I'm
bleeding
he stabbed me with words nine times but
I didn't feel it so it's an issue yeah
it's an issue that I have to work on but
I don't think you can have creativity
without some internal right you have to
have yeah uh I think that's one of the
things that I think you have to be a
little tortured that's what I think yeah
you have to be some great quote and I'm
misquoting it but it was like a lot of
the world's great work has been been
done by people who didn't feel quite
well you know it's like it's true I
think the the caveat there is that it's
this slog and it's this Challenge and
then sometimes it's effortless for two
hours do you know does that yeah so like
we had that yesterday we've been
slogging through writing for months
yesterday we had a couple hours where it
was the faucet was on it was really easy
yeah but mostly it's not I feel bad that
I interrupted your great creative flow
and you had to come here and do the
podcast it was yesterday yeah what if it
was going really great and they said you
got to do that Conan podcast we'd do it
thank you yeah thank you very much I
have to say that right now yeah no but
then their fans would be like what did
we miss out on by the way if you played
other giant have you played Bonnaroo
uh-huh we've done all of them you've
done all of them we did Sony you were
with me when I did Bonnaroo yeah oh
because they have they make years ago
yeah and it was what the hell trench war
it was like trench warfare it's all mud
it takes place in the summer in this in
Tennessee you're in a tent you're in a
tent no and like what I noticed with
your fans is they love to get their
hands on you and you're very generous
about hugging people I'm the same way
I'm I don't mind hugging people huge
mistake at Bonnaroo
no one had nobody had had a shower in a
week yeah oh yeah naked and moist yeah
naked yeah and disgusting people yeah
yeah but happy and high probably like
yeah just you know well you were high
too I was
but not too high I would send you out
for an iced coffee and you'd come back
with like a goose here you go
oh it's not an iced coffee yeah it's
Bonnaroo yeah it was a good time